- What up? I'm Blake Vapes.
On Instagram @BlackeVapes,
and I'm a vapor god.
(intense electronic music)
I first smoked a vape
about three years ago.
Hell yeah, what's up?
Blake Vapes here chillin'
I was able to blow
dope-ass clouds with that
and when Instagram came out and your boy
got an account, people realized, like,
Oh shit, this guy's strip kills again,
and that's where I'm at now, dude.
(intense electronic music)
Pretty much, my page started to grow
after some big pages
started sharing my content.
And here we are, dude, 91k.
(intense electronic music)
A day in the life of Blake Vapes
pretty much, I wake up.
I have a wakin' vape; I just start vapin'
right out of bed, dude.
And then from there, I'll
go to my living room,
chill and vape for a while, think of
some dope-ass ideas I could do to film
for my Instagram.
Then, I get outside, go
to the gym a little bit,
work out, straight up get...
You know, you can't be out
there lookin' like shit, dude.
So that's why your boy
Blake Vapes does that.
And then after that, dude, dinner time.
Your boy crushes it on somethin'
high in protein, obviously.
And then at night time, you
know, if more videos come to me,
I'll film 'em.
If not, then I'll just chill and vape.
(intense electronic music)
I type in all caps to let people know
that everything that I do is straight-up
urgent as fuck.
And when it comes to misspelling
and screwin' up words and stuff,
I don't have time to
correct that shit, dude.
Your boy Blake Vapes is hella busy.
(intense electronic music)
Whenever I post a meme,
I'm pretty much just
tryin' to relate to other people,
because everyone pretty much has a face,
and they make certain
faces in certain situations
and so I like to relate to them by sayin',
"This is the face that you would make
in this particular situation."
So one time, I was vaping
in front of a big-ass ear
and straight-up realized, like, oh shit.
This is that face that you would make
if you were vaping in front
of a big-ass ear, dude.
And it was.
(intense electronic music)
Hi haters. Hi haters.
Hey, camera two. Hi haters.
Camera one, hi haters.
BuzzFeed, everyone at BuzzFeed.
Hi haters.
Pretty much, I have haters
because it's just people
that are hella jealous
of your boy Blake Vapes
killin' the game, and, you know, hate
isn't anything more
than just confused love.
It's people that straight-up
love you so much,
but are so hella jealous that
they can't get on your level,
that they straight-up haveta
spew some kind of emotion
towards you, and it usually is hate
in the form of comments
that are not chill, dude.
(intense electronic music)
Since I started generating so much hate
on my Instagram, my goal has changed
from bein' just top of the vape game,
to now putting out a message
of goodness and anti-hate.
So my ultimate goal in three years
is to have a Ted Talk.
So Ted, if you're
listenin' out there, dude,
I'm tryin' to have a talk.
(intense electronic music)
I can pretty much film a vape
video anywhere at any time.
- [Voiceover] Can you do one right now?
- I could do one right now.
So I gotta make sure that
everything looks good.
What up? Blake Vapes here chillin',
vapin' at BuzzFeed Studios right now
as they make a viral video.
And so from there, what
I'll do, is I'll go through
and I'll drop that shit in iMovie,
and I'll edit it.
I'll put on some fuckin' dope-ass dubstep
and drop that shit.
It'll get, like, 4k likes.
(intense electronic music)
What up? Blake Vapes here chillin',
vapin' at BuzzFeed Studios right now
as they make a viral video.
I straight up make hella viral videos,
but this is one about your boy Blake Vapes
that I didn't make.
(dubstep music)
That's what's up, dude.
(cash register dings)
(intense electronic music)
(whooshes, creak)